tenemos este triángulo grande aquí que
contiene otros triángulos dada la
información que me muestran aquí que el
triángulo bcd es congruente al triángulo
veces a que es congruente al triángulo
s/d y utilizando únicamente esta
información lo que yo quiero hacer a
partir de este dibujo es saber cuánto
miden cada uno de los ángulos que se
encuentran en el dibujo así que
iniciemos con la información que tenemos
sabemos que el triángulo psd es
congruente el triángulo bcd bueno todos
los triángulos son congruentes entre sí
el triángulo bcd es congruente con el
triángulo s d por lo que sus lados y
ángulos correspondientes también serán
congruentes y utilizando el orden de lo
que tenemos escrito observamos que el
ángulo al vértice b de bcd es el mismo
ángulo en vez de bs
y que corresponde al ángulo en el
vértice
d
así que todo lo que he hecho en magenta
todos estos ángulos son congruentes y lo
que también sabemos que el ángulo se
envejece de si este ángulo que está aquí
es congruente con el ángulo se debe s a
bs si este ángulo se que se encuentra
aquí ya su vez es el ángulo ce en ese de
que haber en ese es el ángulo que se
encuentra aquí
estos tres triángulos son congruentes y
de hecho ya podríamos saber el valor que
ellos tienen pero sigamos identificando
el resto de los ángulos regresemos a lo
que nos están diciendo así que el último
que nos queda es de d en b c d
así que en vez de
este este ángulo que se encuentra aquí
corresponde a a
en bc
este que se encuentra aquí y sólo nos
queda por identificar uno que es el que
se encuentra aquí y por consistencia
ésta se debemos de indicar la en
amarillo así que ya tenemos todas estas
congruencias aquí y es el momento de
ponernos a analizar lo que tienen de
interesante para empezar el ángulo bs y
el ángulo bsd y el ángulo de ce son
congruentes y cuando los sumas obtiene
180 grados
si los consideramos en conjunto forman
un ángulo ya no es decir la suma de los
tres es 180 grados por lo que cada uno
mide 60 grados 60 y 60
pues hasta aquí bien y qué más podemos
saber y veamos acá tenemos dos ángulos
que son suplementarios
es decir suman 180 grados y si tenemos
dos ángulos iguales que suman 180 grados
entonces cada uno es de 90 grados estos
de aquí son de 90 grados cada uno o
ángulos rectos y el ángulo en a también
es congruente estos dos por lo que
deberá de ser un ángulo recto también de
90 grados y ahora vamos con estos
ángulos en magenta y tendrá que ser algo
que sumado a 90 más 60 nos dé 180 grados
90 más 60 son 150 para 180 30 30 grados
30 grados y este también es de 30 grados
y bien ya tenemos todos los ángulos pero
podríamos ahora también analizar estos
otros ángulos
estos ángulos exteriores más bien estos
ángulos combinados por ejemplo el ángulo
y el ángulo combinado ave que tiene un
valor de 60 grados este es de 90 y este
de 30 así que es interesante observar
como estos tres pequeños triángulos
tienen ángulos 30 60 90 y exactamente
las mismas longitudes en sus lados
porque son congruentes
pero cuando ensamblamos este triángulo
mayor el triángulo a ver claramente no
es congruente es un triángulo de mayor
tamaño y sus lados tienen otras
dimensiones pero tiene los mismos
ángulos 30 60 90 lo que lo hace un
triángulo similar a los que lo conforman